to transform language to make it more
poetically compelling and the way that's
done is to appeal to the visual the
visual is what's happening it's been
happening for at least 200 years since
the invention of photography and then
color photography and then moving
pictures and then moving pictures with
sent what we are clearly involved in
here at late 20th century is a
technological simulacrum of the world
and we want you know more bandwidth more
pixels higher resolution greater
refresher speed this is why I'm so keen
on virtual reality not because I want to
you know have virtual sex with Marilyn
Monroe or some not headed notion like
that but because I believe this is a
technology that will allow us to show
each other the inside of our own hands
we have never been able to do this I
mean maybe a William Blake for a moment
but as an ordinary cultural enterprise
the most mysterious dimension is other
people you never get at it you know you
can get it the flesh you can get it the
message that's being spoken or conveyed
through dress and gesture but one's
experience of one's self is so
incredibly multi-dimensional and rich
compare that to one's experience of
other people and it's like a universe
away
[Music]